not to send cubits, but to apply gates. The connection to teleportation may not be entirely clear here because, like I
said, this is a simplified version, which we can get away with because t is diagonal. But if you're interested in
learning more, the keywords are quantum gate teleportation.
And we could also do something similar to implement an S gate where this time the only gates we need are a C not gate and a Zgate along with the measurement
which is helpful if we don't have a transversal implementation of an S gate. So that's interesting but it's not
entirely clear that this actually helps. In the case of the Tgate implementation, for instance, we're
managing to apply a TATE to an input state. But to do that, we seem to be applying a TATE to a plus state to get a
magic state. And the situation is similar for the Sgate implementation. The point is that we
don't necessarily need to first create a plus state and then apply a Tate to get a magic state. There are other possible ways to get this state. And in
particular, we can do this without having to worry about propagating errors in whatever computation we're working on because the magic states can be created
separately. This allows for a fault tolerant implementation of a Tate as I'll now briefly describe.
First, we're not actually going to run the simple two cubit circuit shown here, but instead we'll run this circuit using
cubits encoded in whatever error correcting code we're using for our fault tolerant implementation. Which means that the
unitary gates and the measurements are done by fault tolerant gadgets. And that means we also need our
magic states to be encoded as well. So everything will be fault tolerant as long as we can get our hands
on encoded magic states. We are assuming here by the way that we already have a fall tolerant gadget for an escape. If
we were using the steam code for instance, we could simply implement the escape transversely. And for codes for which that doesn't work, one option is
to first use this entire scheme to implement an escape fault tolerantly and then use that implementation here.
Although that's not the only option. But anyway, getting back to the implementation, the important question that remains is how do we get our hands
on an encoded magic state given that we don't yet have a fault tolerant implementation of a Tate to make that
simple? And the key idea is that we can use a probabilistic process to create encoded magic states. And if it doesn't
happen to work out, then that's fine. We can just throw away any failed attempts and try again.
And that doesn't disturb the computation we're actually trying to perform because the creation of magic states is done
separately. A typical way that this is done is through a process known as magic state distillation. And it works like
this. We have a certain circuit known as a distiller. We input into this distiller a collection of noisy magic
states and then measure all but one of the outputs. And if we condition on all of the measurement outcomes being zero,
then what happens is that what comes out is a less noisy magic state, which can then be one of the cubits input into
another distiller. And the process continues until we either fail because one of the measurement outcomes is non zero and we try again or we have a magic
state of sufficiently high quality that we can safely use it to implement a Tate in the computation that we care about.
There are different known ways to build a distiller like this, but they all work in basically the same way, which is that they're decoders for stabilizer codes,
meaning that they're inverses of encoding circuits, which is nice because it means that the distiller can be a Clifford
operation. And finally, this distillation process is actually something that takes place at the logical cubit level. So in reality, it's
all done using gadgets for the distiller and the measurements. This process does have to
start somewhere. But as long as the noise rate isn't too high, it is possible to create noisy but good enough
magic states to start it off. For instance, by applying an actual noisy T gate to a cubit in a plus state and then
encoding that cubit. So that was a very high level description, but hopefully I've given you a rough idea of how this works.
It's quite a bit more complicated than implementing gates transversely, but nevertheless, it offers a way to implement a universal set of quantum
gates fall tolerantly, whereas transversal gate implementations alone can't do that. It's sometimes claimed
that the overhead for using magic states to implement gates fault tolerantly along these lines would be very high
where the vast majority of the work goes into distilling magic states and running the actual computation is more of an
afterthought. But that's actually not so clear and there have been detailed analyses that reveal that this method
could be in fact practical. There are several other known schemes for implementing gates fall tolerantly. Code deformation and code switching are names
associated with some of these schemes and new ways continue to be developed and refined but I won't describe those
methods in this lesson. There is another important issue concerning fault tolerant implementations of quantum circuits and
it concerns the error correction steps themselves. So this is not about implementing gates. It's about doing the
actual error correction. The problem is that if we think about the simple circuits that we
first saw in lesson 14 for measuring stabilizer generators based on phase estimation, we find that they're not
themselves fault tolerant because they could potentially cause errors to propagate within a single code block.
This goes back to the idea that anything involving quantum information is susceptible to errors and that includes the circuits that are themselves meant
to correct errors. This seems rather problematic, but there are in fact multiple solutions known to this problem. I'll mention just a few of
them, although I won't explain any of them in detail. And by the way, if you're getting the idea that fault tolerant quantum computing is
complicated and there are a lot of details to worry about, then that's certainly understandable because it's true. There are a lot of moving parts
here and my intention with this lesson is not to explain all of the details but rather to give you just a basic introduction to how it all
works. One method for fault tolerant quantum error correction is known as shore error correction named after Peter
Shore who first proposed this method. The idea is to perform each syndrome measurement using a so-called cat state,
which is the same thing as a GHC state when we have three cubits, but it can be generalized to any number of cubits that matches the weight of the stabilizer
generator that we're intending to measure. In particular, the circuit shown here works for measuring a stabilizer generator. And it can be
shown that this method doesn't cause errors to propagate within a code block.
It necessitates creating the cat state itself. And to make it work reliably in the presence of errors and potentially faulty gates, the method actually
requires that we repeatedly run circuits like this and make inferences about where different errors may have occurred during the
process. An alternative method is known as steam error correction which was first proposed by Andrew Stein and this